I'm excited our next presenter allowed
us to hit him over the head with a viola
you got to respect that please welcome
two-time Academy Award winner Tom Hanks
the category is directing and all five
nominees this year have chosen projects
of social significance to stimulate the
mind as well as entertain the audience
and the nominees are for Brokeback
Mountain and Lee for Capote the net
Miller for crash Paul Haggis for good
night and good luck
George Clooney from Munich Steven
Spielberg
and the Oscar goes to Angley for
Brokeback Mountain
this is the first Academy Award for
and his third nomination as director for
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon he
accepted the foreign language film Oscar
for Taiwan
oh I wish I know how to quit you first
of all I want to thank two people who
don't even exist or I should say they do
exist because the imagination of any
proof and the artistry of lyric McMurtry
and Diana asana
their names are Ennis and Jack and they
taught all of us who made Brokeback
Mountain so much about not just all the
gay man's and women whose love is denied
by society but just as important the
greatness of love itself thank you thank
you members of Academy for this
tremendous honor and to everyone as
focus features in particular
David Lindy James Sheamus thank you for
your love and support to build pola
Torrey Metzger Irish shark Jody Paolo
many thanks and a special thanks to
David Lee and thanks to my wife Jen Lin
and my boys Hahn and Mason I love you on
Brokeback I feel you with me every day
and I just did this movie after my
father passed away more than any other I
made this for him and finally to my
mother and family and everybody in
Taiwan Hong Kong China shares each other
quenching thank you
you